dear fellow scholars this is two minute
papers with károly Shana if I hear
super-resolution is a research field
with a ton of published papers every
year where the simplest problem
formulation is that we have a low
resolution coarse image as an input and
we wish to enhance it to get a crisper
higher resolution image you know the
thing that can always be done
immediately and perfectly in many of
these detective TV series and yes sure
the whole idea of super resolution
sounds a little like science fiction how
could I possibly get more content onto
an image that's not already there how
would an algorithm know what a blurry
text means if it's unreadable it can't
just guess what somebody wrote there can
it well let's see this paper provides an
interesting take on this topic because
it rejects the idea of having just one
image as an input you see in this day
and age we have powerful mobile
processors in our phones and when we
point our phone camera and take an image
it doesn't just take one but a series of
images most people don't know that some
of these images are even taken as soon
as we open our camera app without even
pushing the shoot button working with a
batch of images is also the basis of the
iPhones beloved live photo feature so as
a result this method builds on this raw
burst input with multiple images and
doesn't need idealized conditions to
work properly which means that it can
process footage that we shoot with our
shaky hands in fact it forges an
advantage out of this imperfection
because it can first align these photos
and then we have not one image but a
bunch of images with slight changes in
viewpoint this means that we have more
information that we can extract from
these several images which can be
stitched together into one higher
quality output image now that's an
amazing idea if I've ever seen one
it not only acknowledges the limitations
of real-world usage but even takes
advantage of it brilliant you see
throughout this video that the results
look heavenly
however not every kind of motion is
desirable if we have a more complex
motion such as the one you see here as
we move away from the scene this can
lead to unwanted artifacts in the
reconstruction luckily the method is
able to detect these cases by building a
robustness mask that highlights which
are the regions that will likely lead to
these unwanted artifacts whatever is
deemed to be low quality information in
this mask is ultimately rejected leading
to high quality outputs even in the
presence of weird motions and now hold
on to your papers because this method
does not use neural networks or any
learning techniques and is orders of
magnitude faster than those while
providing higher quality images as a
result the entirety of the process takes
only a hundred milliseconds to process a
really detailed 12 megapixel image which
means that it can do it 10 times every
second these are interactive frame rates
and it seems that doing this in real
time is going to be possible within the
near future huge congratulations to Bart
and his team at Google for out muscling
the neural networks luckily higher
quality ground truth data can also be
easily produced for this project
creating a nice baseline to compare the
results to here you see that this new
method is much closer to this ground
truth than previous techniques as an
additional corollary of this solution
the more of these jerky frames we can
collect the better it can reconstruct
images in poor lighting conditions which
is typically one of the more desirable
features in today's smartphones in fact
get this this is the method behind
Google's magical night sight and super
resume features that you can access by
using their pixel three flagship phones
when this feature came out our remember
dat phone reviewers and everyone unaware
of the rate of progress in computer
graphics research were absolutely
floored by the results and could hardly
believe their eyes
when they first tried it and I don't
blame them this is a truly incredible
piece of work make sure to have a look
at the paper that contains a ton of
comparisons against other methods and it
also shows
the relation between the number of
collected births frames and the output
quality we can expect as a result and
more thanks for watching and for your
generous support and I'll see you next
time